MAX MEDNIK: Thanks a lot
for coming, you guys.
We have our guest
today, Donnie Eichar.
He's an award-winning
director, producer, and author.
"Dead Mountain,"
Donnie's first book,
examines the Dyatlov
Pass incident,
a mystery that has
confounded investigators
and inspired speculation
for over 50 years.
As the first author to
retrace the Dyatlov hikers'
fateful footsteps in 1959, the
first person outside of Russia
to go to the Dyatlov
Pass in the winter,
and the first person to
extensively interview
Yuri Yudin, the only surviving
hiker, before his death
earlier this year,
Eichar takes readers
through gripping, unpublished
material and photographs;
extensive, exclusive interviews;
first-person investigations;
and finally reveals
the true story
of what happened
at Dead Mountain.
In addition to "Dead Mountain,"
Eichar recently produced
18 episodes of the
groundbreaking MTV documentary
series, "The Buried Life."
He and his team took the show
from the front page of the "New
York Times" to Oprah's
couch and shooting hoops
with President Obama.
Come help me welcome
Donnie to Google.
[APPLAUSE]
DONNIE EICHAR: Thank you.
Glad to be here.
MAX MEDNIK: So tell
us, Donnie, how did you
become interested in
this case overall?
DONNIE EICHAR: Well,
about four years ago, I
was writing a project in
Idaho, a scripted project,
and was actually
procrastinating,
which I know none
of you guys do here,
and I happened upon this story.
And what really intrigued
me right off the bat was,
how was it that a group
of very experienced hikers
left a perfectly good tent
and walked a mile away
from the tent, not
sufficiently clothed,
without the proper
footwear, and walked
to, basically, certain death?
So that central question is
really what pulled me in.
And then as a
documentary filmmaker,
I thought, what
about the hikers?
We're talking nine hikers here.
Originally there was 10.
Who were they?
What's their story?
So I also wanted to get
their story as well.
MAX MEDNIK: Nice.
When did you decide that
you had to go to Russia
to actually study this and
further your investigation?
DONNIE EICHAR: Well, I
should go back and explain
the story really quick,
just in quick story beats.
In January of 1959, the
height of the Cold War,
there was a group of
hikers that set out.
Most of them were
university students,
and they were setting out for an
expedition in the northern Ural
Mountains.
Midway through the trip,
there was one hiker
named Yuri Yudin who turned
back due to an illness,
never knowing he wouldn't
see his friends again.
So two weeks later, the
hikers never return.
So they send out a rescue
team and a search team
to investigate
their disappearance,
and they find the
tent at the campsite,
but the tent is intact.
All their clothing, all their
boots, everything inside,
there's even food sitting
there that was uneaten,
is still intact,
but there's a hole
from the inside leading out.
And they later found the hikers
scattered over a mile away
from the tent.
All of them were
insufficiently clothed
for subzero temperatures.
The majority of them didn't
have on the proper shoes.
Some had violent injuries.
One was missing a tongue.
So again, what baffled me is
how could it be over 50 years
and nobody understands or
has figured out the events
leading to their deaths.
So I started
researching everything
I possibly could here.
Googled like crazy.
And I only came up with a
certain amount of information
that I didn't feel was
sufficient, so I thought,
how can I further this story,
further my investigation?
So I found a man by the
name of Yury Kuntsevich
in Russia who's the head
of the Dyatlov Foundation.
Called him with the
translator, and he
didn't me from anybody else, and
we talked for like 20 minutes.
And he really didn't
give me much information,
but in the end he
said, if you really
want to know more about
this story, come to Russia.
So I hung up the phone.
I thought, oh shit.
He just basically-- it
was almost like a summons,
you know.
So I talked to my girlfriend,
who was seven months pregnant
at the time, which isn't the
best time to go to Russia.
And she said, you got to go.
So basically, I had two
people saying I have to go,
so I actually had to go.
And I jumped on a
plane, and I had
no idea what I
was stepping into.
When I got there,
to Yekaterinburg,
I lived with Yury
Kuntsevich and his family
and ended up uncovering a
trove of materials, the hikers'
journals, the hikers' recovered
photos, the criminal case,
which the attention to detail
back then was extraordinary.
And I also started to get
introduced to the friends
and family of the hikers
and the search teams
and started to interview them.
And that's when the
story began to feel real.
It was no longer a myth
or a rumor or this thing
that I didn't understand, and
it started to become real to me
at that point.
MAX MEDNIK: Nice.
What was it like
actually interviewing
some of the family
members of the hikers?
DONNIE EICHAR: It was
a great experience
because that's when
I knew I had a story.
And I started learning about
the hikers that-- you know,
it was the height of the
Cold War, but some of them
were poets.
Some of them were musicians.
And they were these
gentlemen adventurers,
and there was this
sense of innocence
that existed that I don't
think exists anymore today.
And they would go
off into the woods
for pure escapism
and sometimes just
to recite forbidden poetry,
if you can imagine that,
or just to play songs
that are forbidden.
They would memorize
hundreds of songs.
So this great story
started to materialize,
and I became as
interested in the hikers
as I was the actual
tragedy itself.
But as I was interviewing
the search and rescue teams,
I was also putting
together the story
of the investigation
and all the details
that followed with that.
MAX MEDNIK: Wow.
Tell us about the hikers.
Did they actually have
sufficient experience
and skills to actually
go on such a trip?
DONNIE EICHAR: The hikers
were very experienced, highly
educated.
Most were engineers.
These weren't
university students
going out, getting
drunk, partying.
They were doing it for all the
right reasons in my opinion,
and they were actually working
towards a class 3 hiking
license, which is the
equivalent of a master of sport,
and they were at level 2.
So they would have to cover
a certain amount of area
and do a certain
amount of things
in order to get this
level 3, and that
was what their final expedition
was into the northern Ural
Mountains.
And they specifically
would challenge themselves
and put themselves in
dangerous situations
and extreme situations
in subzero temperatures
in remote areas simply for the
task of challenging oneself.
And they would also
chart uncharted areas
for Google Maps
and all that stuff.
So they would go out
there and actually collect
data for their university
and come back and give it
to them simply to
chart the area.
So I found that really
compelling as well,
just the innocence of it,
and just the camaraderie.
And as I said, they were kind
of like these Jack London type
characters, and they
were very respectful.
And you know, there was love
interest within the group,
but they were gentlemen,
and there was two girls.
They would never show
that love interest
because the goal was
to conquer the distance
and not let any other
personal stuff get in the way.
So I just, I really admire that.
I thought that's pretty great.
MAX MEDNIK: Why do you
think that Yuri Yudin, who
was the only survivor, who
hadn't spoken for so long,
would talk to you, who was an
American from who knows where?
DONNIE EICHAR: Yeah.
Yeah.
Yuri Yudin.
Wow.
Yuri Yudin was the
only surviving hiker,
that turned back halfway,
never saw his friends again.
He had alluded, journalists and
reporters for over 50 years,
and I had always wondered,
does he have survivor's guilt?
But I knew he held the
answers to the stories
in between the hikers'
journals and all the photos,
and he's the only one that
could tell that story.
So ignorantly, I thought
somehow I could find him.
And after two years, I thought,
I'm not going to find him.
But on my second trip there,
I found out that he was there.
And big moment for
me, and I'm going in,
and I finally sit down to
do an interview with him,
and the translator's late.
So we just sat there and
had tea for 40 minutes
and stared at each other, and
I couldn't talk to the man.
And finally, the
translator shows up,
and the first
question he says is,
don't you have mysteries
in your own country?
[LAUGHTER]
DONNIE EICHAR: So I'd
come all this way,
and he hits me
with that question,
and totally not
prepared for that.
And he had a good point.
Of course, we've
got mysteries here.
Why do I care?
I'm not Russian.
But he told me to turn off
my Cold War tape recorder,
so I turned that
off, and then he
proceeded to interview
me for a good 40 minutes
before I could interview him.
But once that trust
was established,
he opened up over two weeks
and told me his personal story,
his background, his childhood.
And told me this story
about these hikers
and these expeditions
that they would do,
and it was sort of like
this sort of cold weather,
motorcycle diaries
style adventures
that they would have.
And in this final
expedition, they
stopped at his school to
tell stories and sing music.
And they stopped at a
wood-cutting settlement
and stayed up all night,
not partying and drinking,
but playing music
and reciting poetry.
And to me, I was just shocked.
I had no idea that was going on.
So he was such an
important part of the book,
to be able to fill all that in.
And it was really endearing.
Every night he would say
to me, I'm praying for you.
And he was praying
for me because he
was worried about me
going on this expedition.
And it was very endearing,
but it was also scary as hell.
And I would lay down
at night, because I
would think, why is
this guy praying for me?
Is it really that dangerous?
I know it's remote, but.
It was an honor for
me to interview him
and that he gave me his
story of all people.
And unfortunately,
ended up dying shortly
after I interviewed him.
So I consider that a
small piece of history
that, for some reason,
he told me about.
MAX MEDNIK: How do you think
you were able to get his trust?
DONNIE EICHAR: I don't know.
I think part of it was,
just crazy American, went
all that way to go over
there and to give it a shot
and to try to get him to talk.
And I think maybe, too,
it was I wasn't as focused
about the tragedy
as I just wanted
to know about his
friends and who
they were as people,
not Russians,
not-- it doesn't matter the
Cold War, just who were they
as people?
Tell me stories
about them because I
wanted to be able to develop
a relationship with them,
as well as the readers
to be able to develop
a relationship with
them, because you have
to care about them
in order to want
to be a part of this story.
MAX MEDNIK: What
was it like actually
retracing the hikers' journey?
DONNIE EICHAR: Well, I
got to a certain point
where I figured out if I'm
truly going to tell this story,
I have to literally
and figuratively walk
in their footsteps,
so I decided I'm
going to retrace their
footsteps the best I could.
And it was a surreal
experience because years ago I
grew up in Florida-- I've
been in Southern California 17
years-- I would never
imagine I would be there
at the gateway of Siberia in
25 below zero, and for what?
I didn't really
know at that point.
But to be able to go to those
places, to go to the school,
and to go to Ivdel, where all
the gulags were that they wrote
about in their
diaries, and to go
to Ushma, which is a
Mansi village where
the indigenous people live.
They were right near there.
And to basically
go from their dorm
to the place on the mountain top
where they had set their tent,
for me, personally,
was extraordinary.
And one big thing
that I realized,
you could see in the
trailer, is to walk
a mile is extremely difficult
in daylight with the best gear
I could possibly buy to be
warm because the terrain
there, it goes from
a few inches of snow
to this much snow
in a footstep, so
it's very, very hard to walk.
And to think that these hikers
left their tent at night,
insufficiently clothed
without footwear,
and walked a mile,
that's when I thought,
wow, this had to
have been something
that they thought it was
safer to leave the tent
than to stay in the tent.
But to also just stand there
and look down into the cedars
where they died.
And it was an extraordinary
experience for me,
and hopefully that's what
I've portrayed in the book.
MAX MEDNIK: Nice.
Did you have some people
locally help you or escort you
during any of the hiking?
DONNIE EICHAR: I did.
I had Yury Kuntsevich, who
is the head of the Dyatlov
Foundation, and two other
people that came along,
Vladimir [? Borsnakov,
?] who is a scientist.
All the people were a little
bit in their golden years,
so that was kind of interesting
going with those guys.
And Yuri Yudin
didn't come along,
which, again, kind
of worried me a bit.
But he just said,
farewell, and had
that look like, I may
not see you again.
But you know, it was
a great experience.
My first trip to
Russia, they made me
an honorary Boy
Scout before I left.
And it may not sound like a
big thing here-- I wasn't a Boy
Scout-- but I was in tears
because they gave me a pin
and taught me the handshake,
and it was a real honor.
So that was a continuation,
when I did the expedition,
of the camaraderie.
And I put my life
in their hands,
and I had a one-year-old at
home on that second expedition.
So I, by no means, climbed
to the top of Mount Everest,
but where I went
was very remote,
and if something happens
there, I'm 30 hours away
from the nearest
third-world hospital.
So I put my trust in their hands
and in your fellow human being,
and it was a great experience.
My translator on the trip wasn't
that great, so a lot of times
I didn't really know what
the hell was going on.
And I had my camera,
my video camera,
and I would flip the
screen backwards.
And it sounds maybe a bit weird,
but through the experience
I would just talk
into the screen
and just see myself, but just
have someone to connect with.
And I later showed
it to my girlfriend,
and she's just
like, wow, I don't
know if I would show
some of this stuff
to people because
it looks like you're
losing your mind,
talking to yourself.
But you know, I just
needed a connection
to talk as I'm going
through all this
because a lot of times I
couldn't really talk to people.
So it was cool.
MAX MEDNIK: That
sounds super intense.
It sounds like through a lot of
the interviews and your travel
you got a pretty deep sense
for just Russian culture
and a lot of interesting
parts of Russian history
because you talked to
a lot of people who'd
gone through an
experience with much
different eras of
Russian history.
Are there some interesting
takeaways or things
that really stuck with
you, not necessarily
related to the story of the
incident, but just in general?
DONNIE EICHAR: Well, you
know, I bought these boots
before I left called
Arctic Pro, and I
don't want to give
away the companies.
I don't want to bag on them.
But these boots, before I
left I was so confident.
They were supposed to be for
50 below zero temperatures.
And I went and had lunch
with my two friends,
and I made him try on the boots.
And I'm like, I'm
going to be fine.
Look at these boots.
So I get there to
Russia, and they
called them elephant boots,
and they were laughing at them.
And they had these
things, I think
they're called
valentis, valenkis.
And it's just basically
a wool covering
that looks like a woolly
mammoth foot or something.
It's the craziest-looking thing.
But they wanted
me to wear those,
and I insisted to wear
my Arctic Pro boots.
So we're out there and
my feet start sweating
because they're not breathing,
and I feel my two toes start
to freeze together.
And I'm like, uh-oh, I
think I have a problem.
And you know, you can't take
your boots off, really, in 25,
30 below zero.
So I said to Vladimir, through
the translator roughly,
I have a problem.
My toes are freezing together.
And he said, welcome to Siberia.
[LAUGHTER]
DONNIE EICHAR: So
the end takeaway,
to answer your question,
is when in Russia,
listen to the
Russians because they
know what they're talking about.
MAX MEDNIK: Nice.
That's good advice.
Talk about your
process in actually
putting the book together.
DONNIE EICHAR: Well, after
my second trip to Russia,
I came back.
The interesting thing was I'd
never even had a book deal.
On my second trip, I financed
the expedition on my own,
spent all my savings, which,
again, I had a one-year-old,
no book deal, going to Russia,
dropped all the savings.
But I got back, and I got
the book deal luckily.
And I put together
this command center
of sort of all the
photos inside my garage,
and I put a timeline of
all the hikers' photos
and all the criminal case
photos, search and rescue,
and put it in
chronological order,
and just started working out the
story from all the interviews I
had done.
And then I started interviewing
Russian scholars and survival
experts, avalanche experts, and
going through every true theory
that might have happened
and ruling them out
until I had nothing,
and freaked out
because I didn't have
an end to the book.
And I went and met with
scientists at NOAA in Colorado,
and they helped me to
push through and find
a good conclusion
without losing my mind.
MAX MEDNIK: Nice.
Speaking of
conclusions, what really
did happen to the hikers?
DONNIE EICHAR: Well--
AUDIENCE: OK.
Anybody who wants to read the
book, get out of the room now.
DONNIE EICHAR: Yeah.
I'm a filmmaker primarily.
This is my first book.
So I consider this
book like a film,
so I can't give away the ending.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE].
[APPLAUSE]
DONNIE EICHAR: Yeah.
And I'm not being coy
at all because I've
got a little flak
with some other things
like, how can you not tell us?
And I'm like, man,
I spent four years,
I can't just give
it away that easy.
Like, read it.
But I will say this.
The lead investigator, Lev
Ivanov, his final conclusion
was an unknown compelling force.
And that was the only case--
AUDIENCE: An unknown what force?
DONNIE EICHAR: An
unknown compelling force.
AUDIENCE: Compelling.
DONNIE EICHAR: Hm-mmm.
So that was the only case that
he ever had that was unsolved.
And what I learned is that he
actually was pretty damn close,
considering he didn't have the
technology and the science.
And the conclusion that I came
up with the scientists at NOAA
completely caught me off guard,
and I could have only arrived
at this conclusion
with modern science.
So I would love to know
what you guys think,
but I think it's a pretty
logical explanation.
MAX MEDNIK: Nice.
Thank you.
We can open it up to
some of your questions,
and I have a handheld mic
that I'll give to you guys.
AUDIENCE: Why did you
decide to undertake
an adventure like doing a book?
Like, what motivated you?
Did you have people
help fund it?
Why are you crazy
enough [INAUDIBLE]
all this time flying
around, to write a book?
I want to hear your
story, your backstory,
how you made this happen.
DONNIE EICHAR:
Well, my backstory
and why I would do this, I'm
a bit ignorant and stubborn,
to be honest.
But I also really wanted
to know about these hikers,
and I felt like there
has to be a story there
behind these 9, 10 hikers.
So that's where the
root of it started.
I have a documentary background,
and I have a personality
as well, as once
I get on something
I become a bit obsessive, which
isn't always a great thing.
But for some reason, I
decided that I could at least
dispel all the false
theories in this
and highlight the
story of the hikers,
and I thought that people
would find it interesting.
And also, the people
in Russia that
never knew what
happened, I never
thought I would give
them complete answers,
but I could shed a light on
a good possibility of what
happened, and maybe they could
have a little better closure
with their lives seeing
a factual account of what
happened to their loved ones.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE].
Why did you decide to
make it into a book
rather than maybe trying
to pursue it as a--
DONNIE EICHAR: Sorry?
AUDIENCE: Why did you make it
into a book rather than, say,
decide to make a documentary
about it, like a film?
DONNIE EICHAR: Well,
on the first trip,
that was my full intention.
I filmed everything
to make a documentary,
but it's a very complex story,
and it's also a Russian story.
So I wasn't quite
sure how I would
do that because I wanted
Westerners to know the story.
I didn't want to just
make a documentary that
would be in Russian.
But I started realizing
the story's so complex,
I better do a book first and
get all the facts down and get
their stories down, and then I
have a platform to make a film.
AUDIENCE: How was this
all perceived in Russia?
Like, I think in the
trailer that you compare it
to the Kennedy assassination,
which is pretty infamous here.
Are you now infamous in Russia?
Like, is this book being
translated to Russian?
What kind of story
is behind that?
DONNIE EICHAR: Good question.
First of all, it hasn't been
translated into Russian yet,
so there really hasn't
been a response yet.
The book's only been out
about 2 and 1/2 weeks.
But the people that I
worked with there, there
was a big response while I was
doing it just because somebody
was out trying to separate
fact from fiction.
Because from my understanding,
all the Russians
that I interviewed, they
have a complete distrust
of government there,
and pretty much everyone
thought the government
had covered something up.
So they feared for
my safety as well,
just carrying around
government documents and stuff.
But as far as their response,
I don't know what it is yet.
I only know in a
small community.
But I'm really excited for
when the book is translated
into Russian to
get their response,
and I hope it's well received.
I did my best job I could of
telling an accurate story, one
that's not jaded, but one
that's also not perfect.
As far as me going there
and solving a mystery,
it's not that.
It's me going there as
an armchair investigator
and embedding myself and seeing
the story that presents itself.
AUDIENCE: So what were
some of the conspiracy
theories about this story?
DONNIE EICHAR: Theories, or
conspiracy theories, or both?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE].
DONNIE EICHAR: Yeah.
Well, aliens, of course, because
you can never prove that.
The top theories were
avalanche, that the hikers
had stumbled upon a
weapons testing area
that perhaps they shouldn't
have seen, the hikers had gone
to a religious site of the
local indigenous tribe there,
the Mansis, and the
Mansi killed them.
There was even a story
that the CIA was involved.
Another theory actually was that
people had escaped from a gulag
and went out there.
But a lot of these
things, some of them
were a little bit more
simple, like the gulag.
First of all, you're in
the middle of nowhere,
and the nearest gulag
is 60 miles away.
So they had, obviously,
fences there with barbed wire
and guards that
would shoot them.
But this thing is, where
are you going to go?
You're in the middle of Siberia.
If you leave that
compound, you're dead.
So to think that prisoners
would go 60 miles on foot,
and then arrive at their tent
site and kill nine hikers,
for what?
So a lot of
theories, really when
I started to get into it
and the true facts of it,
I could cross them
off pretty quickly.
But maybe I forgot
to mention, there
were light orbs seen
in the sky, and this
was in the criminal case file.
And that was one of the
other things that I thought,
uh-oh, OK.
I don't believe in
UFOs, but there's
30 people interviewed
that all saw
light orbs on the same days,
and there's something there.
So I dug into it deeper, and I
explained what those light orbs
were in a logical
fashion through science.
So you know, it was
frustrating at times
because there were
all these theories,
but once I started
clearing them out,
the real frustrating thing
was I got nothing, you know.
And then working with
NOAA was just a godsend.
That answer your question?
AUDIENCE: Yes.
DONNIE EICHAR: OK.
AUDIENCE: So I haven't
read this book yet,
but, you know, we obviously
know it's the Blair Witch.
[LAUGHTER]
AUDIENCE: Can you
at least tell us
what happened to
the guy's tongue?
DONNIE EICHAR: Sure.
This was one of the things
that drew me in as well.
There was a girl named
Luda, and she was actually
the outspoken one of the group.
So some would say her
tongue was cut out
because she spoke too much
as a warning to other people,
don't talk about this.
We'll cut your
tongue out as well.
But the fact of the matter
is she fell into a ravine,
and she was upside
down in the ravine.
She was there for
quite a long time.
And the snow starts to
melt, and there's a stream.
So she's upside down, and
that's the part of her body
that's in the stream.
And there's little organisms
that are in the stream,
for sitting that
long, that eat away
the fleshy parts of the face.
And the tongue is very
fleshy, so that's what it was,
the microbes.
AUDIENCE: Why did you feel
compelled to find a conclusion?
When all other
theories had failed,
why did you feel that you
had to come to a conclusion?
Like say, for example, in
the movie "The Zodiac,"
you didn't see a conclusion,
other than, oh, here's
this book that we never solved.
DONNIE EICHAR: Well,
that's a great question.
You know, I was sort of on
auto pilot at a certain point.
I've got the hikers story, and
I put the whole criminal case
into a linear fashion so
it unfolded as a story.
So what do you do from there?
And that's when I started ruling
out all the different theories,
working with scientists
and different experts.
So by process of elimination,
I eventually reach a point
where I've proven these
theories don't work,
so the only logical
thing to do then
is to try to crack it
and try to find it.
I, by no means, started
off doing this thinking,
I'm going to crack this
50-plus-year-old mystery,
but I thought I'm going to
damn sure give it a try.
And the way it's
presented in the book,
I'm not saying this is it.
This is the end all.
It's here is my theory.
And a group of
scientists, we agree
this is perhaps what happened.
And there's a recreation at the
last chapter of the book that
puts everything
together, sort of a la
"Usual Suspects," where you
see all these things that maybe
didn't make sense, hopefully
make sense of that final night.
And you decide for
yourself, is this it?
But we'll never absolutely know.
There is one thing we
could do is go to the site
and test it with science,
which would be great.
I would love to do that.
So that's something,
perhaps, in the future.
But I didn't want
to present a theory
in the end or a conclusion
that didn't leave
any questions for
people to question it.
Ideally, you read the book.
Another person reads the book.
You go have a beer,
and you debate it.
Some things you might
agree with, some you don't.
But it is presented
factually, and that
was my goal is to separate
fact from fiction.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE] at NOAA,
the scientists you worked with.
Can you tell us a
little more about that?
DONNIE EICHAR: Yeah.
Funny enough, I literally
was left with nothing,
and I sent an email
to Dr. Bedard at NOAA,
and he agreed to meet with me.
And it's a
government-owned agency,
so security is
pretty tight there.
But funny enough, when I arrived
there to meet with all my data
and all my materials, there
was six Russians there,
you know, all these
Russian scientists.
And they were all
really curious as well,
and I think that's the only
reason why they ended up even
working with me because they
had a Russian background.
And once again, why
does this American care?
So we just started going
through everything,
and I was nervous going
there because I was worried
they were going to not
find anything either.
And I thought I had a
theory that was out there,
but-- trying not to
give away the theory.
But they went through the
process of elimination as well,
and they were extremely
helpful, and I
was honored to work
with those guys.
I'm no scientist, you know,
and to be there working
with them and them giving
me the time for a book,
it was amazing.
And it was a really
great experience
and a humbling experience too.
These guys dedicate themselves
to some pretty extraordinary
things.
AUDIENCE: Awesome.
MAX MEDNIK: Any other questions?
If not, Donnie is happy to stick
around and sign some books.
In the meantime, thanks
so much for coming.
DONNIE EICHAR: Thank you.
[APPLAUSE]
DONNIE EICHAR: Appreciate it.